Старий ліфт за лічені хвилини опускає гірників шахти "Великомостівська" на глибину майже 500 метрів.
За наступні 6 годин під землею вони видобудуть понад 200 тонн вугілля.
Втім, через низьку ціну на тверде паливо не зароблять навіть на власні зарплати.
За оцінкою Міненерго, із майже трьох десятків державних копалень, рентабельними є тільки одиниці.
Аби уникнути мільярдних дотацій, уряд планує позбутися збиткових підприємств.
Зо два десятки шахт виставлять на приватизацію чи повністю ліквідують вже до 2030 року.
Ось таке воно наше чорне золото, за рахунок якого ми тут живемо і працюємо!
Начальник видобувної дільниці Анатолій Потопа дбайливо відколює шматки вугілля із вибою шахти "Великомостівська".
Ця копальня найстаріша на Львівщині. Тверде паливо тут добувають вже 62 роки.
Через короткі лави гірникам доводиться декілька разів на рік переходити на нові ділянки, монтувати укріплення й переносити все устаткування.
А невисокі пласти вугілля змушують людей працювати навколішки.
Та невдовзі тут замість шахтарів можуть з'явитися туристи. А видобуток вугілля замінять екскурсіями.
Підприємство було обрано для втілення пілотного проекту - туристичного кластеру. Шахтарі у розпачі і бояться втратити роботу зовсім.
Я думаю, що не повинні шахтарі постраждати.
Багато розмов ведеться про перекваліфікацію людей, але ми прекрасно розуміємо, що шахтарська праця небезпечна, але вона і винагороджується:
і оплатою, і виходом на пенсію раніше в зв'язку з інвалідністю і так далі.
У середньому гірники основних професій у Червонограді заробляють 20-25 тисяч гривень на місяць.
А ще мають 66 днів оплачуваної відпустки. За перевагу вважають і вихід на пенсію після 20 років роботи в забої.
Однак ціна такого "привілею" - втрачене здоров’я, бо дрібний вугільний пил, потрапляючи у легені, викликає серйозні захворювання.
Водночас робота шахтаря у Червонограді досі вважається престижною.
І це навіть попри те, що повну заробітну плату гірники востаннє приносили додому ще у вересні.
Насамперед що турбує - це повний розрахунок шахтаря. Щоб до державної шахти жоден шахтар не мав претензій.
Може й тут залишимося, будемо якимись гідами ходити, якщо запрацює.
Покладів вугілля у "Великомостівський" вистачить ще на 4 роки.
Однак для початку роботи туристичного кластера уряд може і не чекати повного завершення видобутку.
У Міненерго переконують: для реалізації проєкту бюджетних грошей не витрачатимуть.
Розробити детальний план та профінансувати туристичний центр мають іноземні інвестори у рамках енергетичного партнерства.
Далі він перейде в розпорядження Червоноградської ОТГ.
Тим часом директор шахти Андрій Куц уже підрахував: кластер у копальні може обходитися в мільйони гривень на місяць.
Якщо це буде на поверхні шахти, звичайно, набагато потрібні будуть менші капіталовкладення.
А якщо це буде безпосередньо в шахті, потрібно буде мінімум 100 чоловік персоналу,
потрібно буде обстежувати гірничі вирубки, потрібні будуть затрати електроенергії.
Люди, може, і поїдуть, але не багато. Ви просто порахуйте, яка буде собівартість спуску в шахту.
Андрій Куц каже, що не проти буде й сам у майбутньому спуститися в шахту й показати дітям чи внукам, де провів десятки років.
Однак наразі питання перетворення підприємства у туристичний об’єкт несе серйозні соціальні наслідки, бо нині на шахті працює 912 людей.
Найбільш для мене буде болючим, якщо нам не дадуть допрацювати запас. Ото буде найбільш болючим.
Ну, і звичайно, що після закриття шахти всі люди мають бути працевлаштовані.
Це найголовніше, тому що це є добробут нашого міста. Ну, і взагалі нашого регіону.
І наші чоловіки, жінки - вони всі мають бути в сім’ях, а не їздити за кордонами і шукати роботу.
Яку роботу запропонувати тисячам гірників після ліквідації шахт та як не допустити депресивного занепаду вугільних міст,
вже розмірковують у Мінрегіоні. Однак конкретної програми підтримки для гірників наразі не мають.
У нас є декілька ключових напрямків трансформації цих регіонів.
Перше - це малий і середній бізнес, податкові стимули, програма 5-7-9.
Але для того, щоб податися на цю програму, потрібно запропонувати бізнес-модель.
Один із пріоритетів суміжних - це реформування профтехосвіти, щоб дуже швидко протягом 3-4 місячних курсів
можна було отримати нові навички в деревообробній галузі, в легкій промисловості, в дорожній галузі, будівельній галузі.
Червоноград, у якому мешкає майже 80 тисяч людей, нині важко назвати мономістом, що повністю залежить від вугільної промисловості.
На 6 шахтах тут працює близько 8 тисяч осіб. Водночас понад 40% надходжень до місцевого бюджету дають саме копальні.
Постане кілька проблем. Перша - це соціальний момент, працевлаштування. Другий - це екологічний, водовідведення, просідання грунтів.
Як їх відновлювати, як це вплине на помешкання людей.
Що буде з будівлями й усією інфраструктурою.
Чи це буде усе під нуль, як у попередні роки була реструктуризація, чи це так буде, як за кордоном, як я бачив у Німеччині,
де на базі виробничих потужностей шахти десь є музей, десь бізнес розвивається, ну і так далі.
Є екстремальний туризм, є екстремальний спорт. І ми вже навіть придумали тут багато цікавинок, які можна було б на цій території розвивати.
Ми подумали, що можливо спуск в шахту міг би стати тим притягальним магнітом для розбудови всієї інфраструктури.
В очікуванні виплати заборгованостей по зарплаті та подробиць про туристичний кластер
шахтарі "Великомостівської" шукають альтернативний заробіток.
Після роботи гірники здебільшого підробляють: ремонтують техніку, працюють на будівництві чи на власній землі.
Андрій Піско раніше їздив на заробітки за кордон, але аби бути з сім'єю, пішов працювати на шахту.
Нині у родині чекають на появу третьої дитини і зі страхом говорять про можливе закриття копальні.
Бо навіть затримка зарплати - для родини скрута. Щоб заробити хоч якісь гроші, дружина Олена пече на продаж хліб.
Кажу до чоловіка треба купити то, то й то. А він каже, немає грошей, почекай.
І так чекаєш рік, півроку, місяць. Розумієте, тож є витрати буденні. На що чекати? Пішла в декрет.
І думаю, що ж треба щось робити. Хай буде 50 гривень, але хай вони будуть.
Звичайно, матеріально залежні (від шахти) повністю.
Після зміни в забої Андрій не відпочиває, бо має велике господарство, з якого теж нині живе родина.
Тут посіяв пшеницю, там посіяв пшеницю, пасовисько - це все моє.
Добре, що є земля, то ще дякувати землі ми виживаємо.
Ми українці, ми хочемо тут жити, хочемо тут працювати, але, будь ласка, нехай держава звертає на це увагу.
Сьогодні в Україні майже 35 тисяч людей працюють на державних шахтах на підконтрольних територіях.
Від роботи копалень так чи інакше залежать 50 населених пунктів.
Понад 5 мільярдів гривень на дотації шахтарям вже витратила держава цьогоріч.
Тому в профільному міністерстві не приховують, що зміни неминучі. І три копальні ліквідують вже до кінця цього року.
На мою думку, тих шахт, що можуть бути рентабельними, вони можуть бути інтегровані в компанію, яка буде створена на базі Центренерго.
Інші шахти теж у принципі в перспективі можуть знайти приватного інвестора,
але в більшості своїй, якщо це і буде приватизація, то інвестори будуть зацікавлені передовсім в інфраструктурі.
При трансформації вугільної галузі уряд планує взяти за основу досвід інших європейських країн, зокрема Німеччини.
Там останню вугільну шахту закрили у 2018 році,
однак копальням здебільшого дали друге життя у вигляді музеїв, індустріальних парків та технологічних або культурних осередків.